Vermont is debating a bill that would
allow emojis to appear on license plates
yes if not crazy Andy can you imagine if
we allowed emojis on California license
plates mm-hmm be crazy yeah a Beverly
Hills doctor might have this on his car
I can plump your lips you know or you
might see this on a Lamborghini sports
car very small penis booing sir what are
you booing are you insulted could you
drive a Lamborghini no I'm grant Frasier
from the National eggplant Growers
Association and you just used an
eggplant emoji as a symbol for a penis
and that's not cool come on everybody
this is the eggplant to symbolize a
penis doesn't make it right folks on
behalf of America's eggplant farmers
please limit your use of the eggplant
emoji to convey interest in the buying
selling cultivating cooking or eating of
actual eggplants anything else and
you're hurting farmers okay but okay
right come on can't you can't you at
least see why people use the eggplant
emoji
no I can't it's botanically incorrect
people eggplants aren't veiny
eggplants don't have two plums growing
under them eggplants don't shrink in
cold water
well okay baby if you're gonna be
literal it isn't exactly like a penis
thank you
eggplants are a food people an amazing
food an eggplant starts out as a tiny
seed that's plunged into a mound of
moist fertile soil and before you know
it it's growing larger and turning more
purple and then one day you're looking
out over your patch and you see a nice
one and you say to yourself man I would
love to have that inside me so yeah so
you grip it and you pull it and you take
it inside and you stick it in a warm
oven and when the time is right by God
you pull it out of the oven and into
your eager mouths and I ask you does
that sound like a penis to you oh come
on wait a minute oh my god I see it now
from now on no more eggplants it's
bananas for me
brought to you by the banana Council
bananas we also look like this
you know yeah I don't I don't care if it
makes the show unwatchable I want him to
eat that whole thing yeah eat that whole
thing
eat it all right
[Applause]